[Music]
hey a lot of people think that Super
Tuesday is the big story of the day
that's if you look you can open a
newspaper you know this is a Tuesday
Super Tuesday well judging by local news
apparently there's an even bigger story
that's sweeping the nation right now
here's a look at today's real top story
if your email inbox is out of control
and you've given up sorting it out
a Baltimore company thinks it has a
solution for you could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of email overload could this be the end
of your email overload could this be the
end of email overload would this be the
end of email overload could this be the
end of email overload could this be the
end of that email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end to email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end of email overload could this be
the end of email
could this be the end of email overload
could this be the end of email overload
overload
they never answered the question I know
it must be a coincidence yeah it's just
Quincy all those hard-working journey